hello John Perry here in today's video I
sit down with Drew McCoy he is from the
YouTube channel genetically modified
skeptic we met to chat about intelligent
design creationist Stephen Meyer Meyer
recently did a podcast with Joe Rogan
and as you might expect many of the
things Steven Meyer said about biology
and psychology on Joe's platform were
slightly less than accurate
so Drew and I decided that we would
respond we have a shorter more polished
video over on Drew's Channel but that
one only addresses two of Stephen
Meyer's claims right here on this
channel we have a much longer more
in-depth and much more casual
conversation about the entire podcast we
even talk about the Joe Rogan phenomenon
in General Andrew and I we debate a
little bit we we keep it very friendly
but we debate about the issue of
platforming has Joe Rogan done a really
bad thing by having a creationist on his
show should Educators like Drew and
myself should we have debates with or
invite creationists onto our platforms
to talk it's a fairly tricky issue we
talked briefly about that old debate
between Bill Nye and Ken Ham is it
possible that that debate backfired and
is what caused the funding of the arc
encounter we also talk about a more
recent debate between Dave Farina and
James tour we end by revealing who our
personal favorite science YouTubers and
podcasters are the conversation is
fairly long but Drew is a super
fascinating guest we had a wonderful
conversation if you like my channel if
you like other stuff that I've made
you're gonna love this I recommend
treating it like a podcast you can
listen to it while you're driving or
doing your dishes I did include some
visuals for those true fans those Heroes
out there who actually do want to sit
and watch the entire thing without
further Ado here is the brilliant The
Talented the lovely Drew McCoy the goal
today is to talk about this intelligent
design conversation that was had on The
Joe Rogan podcast so that was between
Stephen Meyer I'm saying his last name
right it's yes Meyer not mayor which
that's now been what two weeks ago the
two three weeks something like that yeah
yeah and you and I are still in the
works we're still producing a more
polished conversation about that over on
your channel and I just thought it'd be
fun to also make this one with that's
casual that we can just kind of chat
about even The Joe Rogan phenomena in
general and then intelligent design in
general I
just responded to chat more casually
about this yeah to the things that make
me like pretty frustrated so this is
sure to be an interesting conversation
we'll do before we dig into that though
just tell everybody who you are who is
this true character yeah so I'm Drew I
have a YouTube channel called
genetically modified skeptic I uh
started my YouTube channel trying to
kind of
debunk and argue against alternative
medicine claims and then I started
talking about how alternative medicine
claims overlap with religious claims and
now I talk more about religious claims
but uh I may have started my channel
kind of as an anti-theist being like Oh
religion is just bad we need to
eliminate religion to her now I I don't
have a an attitude quite like that I
Define myself as a pluralist but I do
think that you know just like the the
new atheists say religion can be harmful
in all of those ways I just don't think
that all religion is always harmful in
all of the ways that someone like
Christopher Hitchens or Richard Dawkins
would say uh and so I I like to take a
little bit more of a uh sociological
view of of religion which is uh informed
by actual long-standing research and and
study rather than just kind of by like
well I don't think that Evangelical
Christianity is true so therefore I am
very rational and I don't need religion
in any kind of way right so yeah make
videos about religion and skepticism on
YouTube do you consider yourself to be
in like the atheist YouTube world yeah
yeah definitely and uh I mean I I think
that at least in America and probably in
Britain too but primarily the US and
Canada uh the word atheist like the
label atheist is kind of a political
identifier more so than it is an
indication of specific position like
people want to be like oh well you know
agnostics are really just fence sitting
atheists and I would say I am agnostic
philosophically speaking I am agnostic
philosophically I'm not an atheist like
if you want to talk about specific
positions I don't assert that like no
God exists and I know that or whatever
uh I'm agnostic on that however in the
US when you identify as agnostic people
see that differently they take that
differently than oh well you're just you
know
like you don't necessarily have a belief
there but you don't think it's knowable
it's more like okay so you're amenable
to the gospel like you you are ready to
be brought into the fold at any time
it's just that you have some questions
I'm like no I mean specifically with
Christianity I they would call me an
atheist but I don't think that on the
global scale of all other religions that
means that I'm an atheist so yeah I'm a
part of atheist YouTube uh I made me the
the biggest atheist YouTuber who's not
philosophically an atheist so my main
YouTube channel stated stated clearly I
just teach biology and this channel you
know I just started answering a lot of
more in-depth questions that people had
about biology here but most of the
questions people end up giving me are
religious base so I've ended up talking
a lot about religion on this channel
which is never my intention it's not
what gets me up in the morning right I
mean I I really like to talk about
biology and it's just that there's these
overlaps these the two end up butting
heads more than I think they should
right I very very much relate to what
you've said because my my interests and
my everyday life is just like sociology
psychology anthropology that's just yeah
and and religious studies you know those
are the things that I like to study and
I I'm not consuming polemical materials
I'm not really consuming you know
philosophical debates surrounding
religion I'm just you know reading books
that are
just kind of mainstream you know works
on on these things by by accomplished
Scholars and then I I happen to notice
that some of the main opponents too like
mainstream very uh high-level
scholarship are people who are in the
camp that I came from which is
evangelical Christianity from the US so
that's why I have to talk about it in a
way to defend something else which I
don't think has to have something to do
with religion necessarily
you mentioned earlier that like atheism
is kind of a political thing in the U.S
it seems like
even on like uh you know the internet
the the YouTube atheist world that
there's there's a lot of political
diversity uh
would you say that's the case or is or
is there kind of an alignment among
internet atheists I mean there's
definitely political diversity like in
any group but I will say that as far as
polls that I have seen that are that are
recent uh the the word that a person can
use to describe themselves as belonging
to a progressive liberal camp in the U.S
besides for a progressive is actually
atheist like atheists are the most
politically active religious group in
the entire country and also they tend to
be like they score lowest in things like
anti-lgbt attitudes uh you know Pro like
affirmative action uh Pro like social
welfare things that are traditionally
are typically Progressive left issues so
uh overwhelmingly statistically speaking
atheists are progressive
liberals uh I wouldn't really say
leftists exactly uh but yeah there there
are definitely people who are not who
don't fall into that camp and they're
often pretty loud because they're a
minority within a minority uh it's a
conservative atheist is like someone
that's almost politically homeless like
they don't belong with the atheist but
they don't belong with most uh
conservative people either so I I I I'm
politically not aligned with those
people but I do have empathy for them in
in understanding like what it's like to
feel like you know no one's on your side
I've been there before
yeah yeah so I I live in Canada and now
I've been here for
I think almost five years
uh and I'm in the French part of Canada
and so there's like
there's more of just like the language
barrier even causes more of a
I guess buffer between
the way that people think here and like
American politics like when my wife
tries to look at what's going on in
America she's so confused like why why
is everybody
have to be a like a liberal or
republican like she's it's it's very
confusing her just to see the kind of
the extremes that people go to today
we're going to talk about this podcast
that happened on Joe Rogan's uh platform
you know I've noticed that he is very
much hated by a lot of American liberals
I tried looking this up like why is it
that American liberals hate him so much
or tend to well Autumn don't but one of
the main things that kept coming up is
he platforms controversial figures a lot
yeah yeah and this is a it's a tricky
thing for that like this this
platforming issue like I go back and
forth on it a lot so in this case for
example he's had an intelligent design
Advocate on I've had people on my
channel I've had uh Rob Stadler who's an
intelligent design guy he writes for The
Discovery Institute I've had Perry
Marshall who wrote a book that and he
worked with a lot of people in the
intelligent design world in the case of
Rob he was upset with me for stuff that
was in one of my videos so I was like
well come on and talk to me about it
yeah and so I had him on twice so I gave
him something like four hours is all
together to talk about it he seemed like
fine with everything that we were
talking about when we were talking about
it but now he writes a bunch of articles
about me on the Discovery Institute
website so I didn't know what happened
something flipped him to uh kind of go a
little bit berserk but I've seen videos
of Joe Rogan where it's just Clips where
it's like the most obnoxious things that
he's ever said you know yeah and people
are yeah they're kind of demonizing him
but then when I watch interviews that he
does with people I'm impressed by how
good he is at at pushing people that
he's interviewing without being rude
like yeah it's he's a an extremely
skilled interviewer yeah I definitely
share that and then he's he's very
skilled um I may have a slightly more
negative uh opinion on that and and
maybe that's because I'm a part of like
a political camp that you know my in my
group of friends people are like oh yeah
Joe Rogan sucks even if they haven't
necessarily watched Joe Rogan and that's
just kind of like the party line
um so with me like kind of preparing for
this Converse station for this podcast I
really try to do my best to keep that
out of it and talk about like the
specifics uh because I think that's
where I can be more useful is talking
about like you know what criteria should
there be for like platforming a person
or like putting on a debate and and
things like that rather than just being
like Oh you know like well Joe Rogan is
like is an
so I I may not personally care for him
but that's not really what I'm trying to
discuss you know in this one just
hopefully to be more productive than
that I guess I do have a one principle
for like deciding who I would have on my
Channel and that is is the person going
to be a dick or not like yeah there's
certain creationists that would not have
on like I wouldn't have Ken Hoven on
because he's just like he's just really
obnoxious it's like can we have an adult
conversation or not that's my criteria
and I don't really yeah I guess I don't
care even how extreme some people's
views are
beyond that because
um you you can have a good if you can
have a good conversation it's going to
be interesting and you can you can pick
apart uh
some of these ideas that that are so
controversial right now that they're
causing just schisms in our country
right but I mean the the way that I
think about this is kind of um like a
sociological perspective that like a a
huge uh portion of of sociologists like
scholarly sociologists tend to hold to
is that when there is uh large-scale
change happening especially quickly and
it doesn't have to be like just cultural
change it can be change in like industry
and the economy in technology
these things tend to like as Carl Sagan
said uh you know make people uh see
demons right like it it makes them uh
start to resort to intuition and
tribalism just kind of like these parts
of our minds that are have been with us
since before we could even call
ourselves human and uh we we operate
kind of on Instinct we tend to get
really polarized we engage in more like
aggression uh one of the one some one
thing that's actually been studied uh
quite rigorously is that when people are
scared they tend to latch on to a very
strong domineering male figures As
Leaders uh yes okay so if you look at
like someone like Donald Trump like he
is that he is the perfect embodiment of
something like that
um and in some ways physically maybe
yeah yeah well that's a brand at least
that's the brand right like whether or
not he is that is to be seen but yeah
he's he's very aggressive in his way
he's he's yeah he's almost impossible
for people to to win debates against
because he's he actually is really good
uh at just
like
pigeon show pushing people and
triggering them and making them do
things that are stupid when they're
reacting to them and then and then he's
able to he's very skilled at harassing
people so one one thing that I've seen
people
say and this is Joe Rogan included when
they're when they're talking about how
polarized everyone is they're like okay
well the the the solution to this is
that we actually talk to each other we
actually have conversations with each
other we actually see each other face to
face I actually I totally agree with
that humanizing the other side is a
primary solution it is one of the
primary solutions to this however I
don't think that having conversations
with the other side
means necessarily like you have to
invite on Graham Hancock and Alex Jones
onto your podcast or else polarization
is going to just get worse I I don't
think that the when I'm saying I think
that we need to talk to each other I
mean uh you know some of my neighbors
like have like conservative bumper
stickers and stuff on their cars and yet
when I walk by them I don't scorn them
and go you know oh you suck right like I
I try to just show my Humanity to them
and they usually do in return most
people will uh and and it's really a
it's a bottom-up solution I I I don't
really think that it works being like
oh we just need to be willing to talk to
everyone in like this massive public
forum where people are going to be
communicating about this public forum
and what was said in it through like
purely text channels right so basically
what this means is I don't think that
Joe Rogan having a conversation with
anyone and everyone and large podcasters
having a conversation with anyone and
everyone is really the thing that
applies that solution the best uh I I
think we have to be more nuanced than
that if you want to talk to your Q Anon
neighbor though I do encourage that like
you should you should talk to people I
think that ultimately is more fruitful
than hurtful okay so let's let's talk
about this specific podcast actually
before doing that even though
I just want to talk about the The
Discovery Institute in general like what
it is that their goals seem to be
The Discovery Institute for those who
don't know they're the ones who are
behind the intelligent design movement
so the it's this kind of newer version
of creationism where they've they've
tried to Brand it as being more
scientific and more sophisticated they
try to say there's an intelligent
designer it might be God it might be
some other intelligent designer and that
you know the most famous example I think
is Michael be he's claim that there is
irreducible complexity in biology and he
does not think that that sort of
complexity could evolve uh through
through natural means through means that
are similar to darwinian Evolution what
they're doing is they're trying to
promote this idea that science can't
actually explain biology they're they're
quite uh loud about or at least Stephen
Meyer seems quite loud about the idea
that they're not all Christian
um which
technically is true right like not
everybody that is an intelligent design
Advocate or buys into it in some way is
Christian but is the Discovery Institute
itself run primarily by Christians is it
being donated to primarily by Christians
grants by Christian institutions I don't
know a whole lot about specifics of
their funding they have documents on
because there are there are Charities so
they have documents about their taxes
and stuff like that and
like they have like an 11 million dollar
a year budget
uh wow
I know that the John Templeton
Foundation used to fund them and then
they got upset with how extreme it got
and so
at least publicly they stopped funding
them do you know much about the John
Templeton Foundation yeah I do and and
you know uh I mean I even have friends
who are Scholars of of religious studies
and they're not particularly religious
themselves and they've been given grants
by the John Templeton Foundation like
it's it is it's a religious
trust or religious fund you know John
Templeton was like an evangelist
basically but uh they they do fun like
scholarly institutions that are you know
highly credible yeah they fund a lot of
very legitimate research in biology and
economics and and so on but you know
they yeah the the founder was
he's definitely was not like a normal
like Evangelical Christian he had a lot
of uh unusual views but he
yeah he basically he's he's very much
against this idea that uh it was the
struggle for existence and that's
basically it that created the human
spirit and everything so he's yeah he's
trying to uh
he's trying to find
where his spirituality fits into science
and it's controversial within especially
within the field of biology like when
people take grants from them uh
it can be a problem for them for their
reputation yeah but
it's a complicated situation because
they're also giving millions and
millions of dollars and when there's a
giant pile of money sitting there that
can help you do your research you're
just going to want to jump through the
Hoops that you need to to get that money
so you can do your research because
that's what you're there to do so it's a
and the the other the argument that I
have you know I've never taken money
from them but
um I I do know people that have and I I
try to defend them a little bit against
this this this backlash by saying look
if good researchers aren't taking that
money then quacks are going to take it
that they're giving that money out every
year so we might as well be encouraging
good researchers to take that money and
do good research with it yeah yeah no I
totally I totally see that reasoning I
mean there there are people that I know
that have taken that and I'm glad that
it is them instead of some other
um
Scholars from uh devotional institutions
that like you know they have written
statements of faith that they have to
sign before they're even allowed to
attend or work there and the John
Templeton Foundation will fund people
who work at things like Biola you know
and I would really rather someone from
Boston University or Duke or something
take that money right so yeah I know
that they funded The Discovery Institute
early on but there there was some sort
of a fight like they didn't like how
extreme it was or how
um I mean if you look at the discovery
institute's tactics there's a lot some
of what they do is totally fine it's
they're criticizing
scientists that say stuff that's that go
beyond what they've actually discovered
I think that's totally fine people
should be ridiculed for overstating
their claims yeah the other thing that
this The Discovery Institute does that's
fine is they point out where are these
mysteries in science but the the
obnoxious thing they do is that they
just lie about stuff and they'll
exaggerate they try and prick their
audiences into thinking that we don't
understand things as well as we actually
do so that's very frustrating a lot of
the tactics are are really kind of
purely rhetoric you know they're they're
the same as you are going to get if you
were going to a Christian apologetics
organization
um you know you you go with like stand
to reason Ministries which was started
by a Biola graduate Greg kokel uh and
you know you you look at like stand to
reasons website and the rhetoric that
you're going to see the wording that
you're going to see specifically about
like uh the board goof flanking theorem
right is is something that
stands to reason itself just copied
homework from from William Lane Craig
who has been
like discredited over and over and over
with his use of the board board guthin
theorem you know this is this was a
specific theorem that In classical
physics like means X Y and Z it doesn't
mean that it is absolutely without it
out proven that the beginning of the
universe happened with like this
specific type of origin event and yeah
so uh you'll you'll see things like that
and when you come from a background I
think like mine and like yours where we
were raised with
um really comprehensive and high level
apologetics surrounding us constantly
like our our educational process had to
do with kind of deconstructing the way
that that rhetoric works and the way
that it kind of morphs your thinking
um yeah and so when I look at something
like The Discovery Institute I'm just
seeing something like you know Frank
Turek or Greg kokel or William Lane
Craig saying things in a highly
manicured way that isn't necessarily
directly lying but to a lay person who's
not familiar with all the terminology
that's being used you're like you walk
away from an article going
wow most scientists actually believe
that like there is no other idea except
for that the Big Bang was the definitive
single uh origin event for all of the
universe and that you know any anything
about like a big crunch theory is
laughed out of the room and people
actually agree with with like Christians
who uh who propose science more often
than they agree with like atheistic
scientists you know Stephen Meyer likes
to say that uh he said several times in
the in the Joe Rogan podcast that
um atheistic materialism it's funny that
he likes to call it that because like
materialism doesn't have to be atheist
an Atheist Atheism doesn't have to be
materialistic uh he he says like it is
becoming very exotic
he doesn't usually say where but he's
implying to the layperson it's it is
unusual to be an atheist if you are like
really smart and you're in you're an
academic which like is not true but it
also is kind of beside the point I think
what The Discovery Institute is doing I
keep seeing them make what I would just
call god of the gaps arguments which are
not at all interesting to me like I
don't I just when there's a mystery I
like to put a question mark there
instead of put God there right what
they're trying to do is they're trying
to argue against this string of logic
that some people have used to get to
atheism and that is this idea that
religion exists to explain Mysteries you
know science can also explain Mysteries
and it seems to be doing a better job
than religion therefore we don't need
God anymore I don't know how many people
are atheists because of that line of
reasoning but you know there are there
are quotes you can find like Richard
Dawkins said and I wrote this down here
um
he said and I think it was
the blind watchmaker one of his books he
said Darwin made it possible to be an
intellectually fulfilled atheist and by
that he's basically saying you know
Darwin explained
complexities of life therefore we can be
intellectually fulfilled atheists
because that that would have been a big
huge mystery before Darwin and it would
have given you pause like uh there must
have been a Creator the other one is
from Tim mentioned his who comedian I'm
sure a lot of people know him
if he's like throughout history every
mystery ever solved has turned out to be
not magic these are just little little
quotes that that people cling on to and
I know The Discovery Institute talks
about this this uh Dawkins quote all the
time in fact there's a like a whole book
where that's the title of the book yeah
um fulfilled atheist and and so what
they're trying to do is they're trying
to say oh you think that Darwin can
explain life Well it can't because
there's the origin of Life how did that
happen or there's irreducible complexity
Darwin can't explain that which actually
it can but that's a that'd be a
topic for another day but the I mean the
origin of life is a genuine mystery the
irreducible complexity is not a genuine
mystery that's a fake mystery they are
attacking
basically theories that that are
explaining a lot about the universe so
they're trying to give people a reason
to still need God I I would actually say
that
from my read on on Meyer it seems like
when it comes to his own personal story
of coming to Faith and when it comes to
what he usually brings the conversation
around to when you're when you're
discussing science and and like
atheistic materialism is not the idea
that you can be intellectually fulfilled
as an atheist but that you can be like
spiritually fulfilled uh that you can
have some kind of deeper sense of
meaning or fulfillment in your life uh
you know he he often equates atheism or
materialism without right nihilism and
yeah and it just is so common that
you're talking about science and then
Stephen Meyer is like but the problem
with this is that you can't actually
have like certainty you can't found this
in some fundamental philosophical
principle which also means that life has
no meaning and you're like whoa where
where does the life has no meaning thing
come from it seems you know very sudden
but I would say most people who are not
more studied in this stuff hear
something like Dawkins saying that you
can be an intellectually fulfilled
atheist and they don't just hear that
they they're hearing that you can be an
atheist and you can get the kind of
fulfillment that you might get within a
Christian framework and I don't think
that people of The Discovery Institute
who are Christian especially Stephen
Meyer who I'm most familiar with
want people to do that because they they
themselves don't have that experience
which is okay you know they don't have
to find fulfillment as an atheist so
they want to be Christian to find like
good feelings and fulfillment that's
fine
um but it they're almost saying like
pronouncing that no one can have a
different solution to this than they can
uh by solution you're saying that I like
the danger is
just self-destructive nihilism right I
mean that that is something that a lot
of people struggle with it like right
now that like I just I just looked at a
survey on
um
I can't remember the name of the group
that does these surveys on religion
could be Pew research or yeah yeah okay
that's one they did one on a belief in
an afterlife and they found that even
though atheism slash non-religious
people I think it's
I don't remember what it is it's
surprisingly high right now in the U.S
but uh only 17 percent believe there is
no afterlife or are confident that there
is no afterlife
and if you think about just historically
you know I've been getting into like
Greek mythology lately a very few people
have gone throughout their lives
believing that when you die you just die
like that's a super rare thing for
humans to believe all throughout history
I think a lot of people do
feel like if that's the case then
everything is pointless and there a lot
of people are terrified of that nihilism
and I I don't know how you uh see that
or deal with that or
yeah so first of all I mean I'll say
that
the idea that nihilism is exclusive to
uh like atheism or materialism or
atheistic materialism compounded with
the idea that it is found in just one
place one philosophy
that idea within our culture comes from
Christian thinking it comes from
Christian culture Christian Renaissance
and Enlightenment thinkers
um going you know if you uh like
Dostoyevsky is like saying that if you
if you leave religion then you will have
like no guiding moral uh or if you leave
Christianity you'll have no guiding
moral principle you'll be nihilistic
everything will be hopeless everything
will be meaningless and that like you
have to seek God in order to to deal
with that but that that is simply not
the way that that issue has been
conceptualized throughout all culture
and history this is not Universal it is
a Christian idea specifically to think
that they are the only ones who have the
answer and that atheists are somehow
specifically you know uh vulnerable to
nihilism and like suicidal ideation as a
result of this uh and and so I see them
pushing this this attitude which kind of
translates to them being very
dominionist you know like uh The
Discovery Institute doesn't just want to
challenge Sciences it seems like they
want to challenge anything that's like
an an anti-christian idea because
ultimately they want you to find meaning
in their religion just like they do the
way that they're doing that is they're
trying to say that science doesn't know
stuff that's the main way that they're
doing this is that science doesn't have
good answers I was raised Mormon I love
the religion quite a while ago and
one of my cousins was leaving and she
was asking what do you replace it with
in the church we have answers to
everything we know what's going to
happen after we die we know like why
things were created we know all these
things what do you replace that with I
mean you can you can replace part of the
creation story with an understanding of
biology but what about all the other
stuff and I was like well I I just
replaced it with a question mark like I
don't know I don't know what happens
after we die I assume that we just stay
dead but a lot of people that I know uh
like they they just want answers and I I
just feel like having questions is is
okay so when when they're attacking
science and saying oh look they don't
the the origin of life isn't completely
solved I'm just like yeah I know like
you could watch all of my videos on the
origin of life and that's mentioned in
every single one of them this is not yet
a solved problem yeah very clear about
that and my teaching that's that my the
textbooks that I've seen are clear about
that as well uh there was a part in the
interview where um in in The Joe Rogan
interview where Stephen Meyer said that
uh one of the people in his group
finally got Richard Dawkins to admit
that the origin of life is not solved
and I was just I I was laughing at that
because and Richard Dawkins very first
book The Selfish Gene he talked about
that he's like no one was there we don't
know how it happened and it's it's an
unsolved problem and then he gives one
of several scenarios that have been
proposed but he's super clear about that
in his first book and then in uh I think
is the blind watchmaker he has an entire
chapter about this uh and and it's just
peppered throughout all this stuff he's
been talking about this since forever
and I mean what The Discovery Institute
is trying to do is they're trying to say
these scientists it's not just that they
don't know everything they're lying to
you they're trying to trick you into
thinking they know everything
that no that is not what people are
doing this this idea that uh having
Unsolved Mysteries is inherently a
source of Despair that you know not
knowing where you're going to to go
after you die if anywhere you know is a
is a cause for uh despair that you know
you don't you don't know exactly where
the human race came from is a is a
horrible cause of Despair uh all of
these things these are kind of Christian
assumption assumptions that are based in
uh you know Christian long-standing
Christian thought and they're they're
baked into uh like intelligent design
type movements you know like you have to
undermine uh certain ideas of like well
just saying I don't know in certain
cases rather than just jumping to a
conclusion is actually the only thing we
can do the only thing that's it's that's
except they'll be like no but that's not
good enough because you know it makes us
it inevitably inherently in humanity
will make us despair so therefore we
must solve it but if you step outside of
a Christian Paradigm I mean you look at
like the ultimate fulfillment of a
Buddhist life for instance is to
literally Escape existence it's to be
annihilated to not exist anymore uh I
don't think that it's inherently an
intuitive notion to to think that like
going to heaven after you die is what
humans inherently want to know your
specific Creator to know all of the
answers to all of these things is
inherently what all humans want and that
all religious systems must strive to for
people to feel fulfilled it's it's
historically it's just not not true
yeah well it's it's interesting when I'm
like studying Greek mythology and stuff
that their views of death are usually
like horrible like you there's not even
like a heaven that exists
um it's just like you go to this spirit
world that just seems like it kind of
sucks right
uh which that's that's a weird it's
weird that that belief became popular
yeah but with Buddhism I'm actually I I
don't fully understand it because I'm
obviously with with Buddhism there's um
when they talk about Enlightenment
they're talking about becoming one with
the universe right
and that it is a type of annihilation
but that's different to them than death
death I mean there's a lot of Buddhists
that believe in reincarnation or maybe
Enlightenment I mean in in Buddhist
theology obviously it's very diverse
it's much much older than Christianity
so it's like uh you know Judaism
Zoroastrianism and Buddhism are like our
our oldest religions that have a
historical through line from from the
past to now
um and
yeah in in Buddhism there are some
people who do take an idea that it's
like if you become enlightened then um
you reach a state that is kind of like
Bliss but the I think the most
long-standing popular historical view of
Enlightenment and Buddhism is escaping
the Perpetual cycle of Rebirth of
reincarnation
um okay they're they're I think the the
fundamental Assumption of Christianity
is like life is necessary and life is
always good
um and that that kind of comes out of
Judaism to a certain extent but with
Buddhism it's like no life is a core
component of life in existence is
suffering so if you want to escape
suffering You Must Escape existence and
so you become enlightened in order to
like be
free from from rebirth sometimes that
means you're like still existent but
outside of our kind of existence but a
lot of the time it does just mean that
you just don't exist anymore
um I just I
I know people uh actually very close to
me who personally were raised Christian
and always found the idea of Heaven to
be actually very frightening and the
idea of annihilation is much more
comforting so I just don't think there's
a universal answer to what makes people
feel fulfilled my wife is a nurse she
deals with death all the time because
she's just around it all the time and so
we talk about death all the time I mean
it's a conversation we have
not daily but
quite a bit but it's it's not something
that I'm excited about but I I have not
been plagued by this dread and and
nihilism that people talk about I know
that other people do though A friend of
mine faith is one of these things that
kind of just breaks if people have a
belief in God some sometimes it just
stops and they can't do anything about
it even if they want to keep believing
in God
he went through this and it's been super
hard for him because he really is uh
struggling with this super negative form
of knowledge there's positive nihilism
as well but he's uh he's just plagued by
this it's really bad for him I feel like
that that is behind a lot of what The
Discovery Institute is fighting against
it's like they they they're trying to
stop people from falling into that brand
of nihilism it's a noble Pursuit when
you understand their perspective
however I think that their perspective
is woefully uninformed it's based in a
very siled and dominionist way of
thinking we have the one true path to to
truth and and that's it no one else has
it more right than us which is it's a
fundamentally anti-academic
attitude to have right yeah
yeah and and the main thing that bothers
me about what they're doing is when they
just misrepresent in slander individual
scientists I mean they've done that to
me too I'm not trying to get Petty and
talk about that here but it's like when
they this this thing that I mentioned
with Richard Dawkins where they're
trying to trying to make it seem like
they finally got him to admit that the
origin of life is not solved it's like
okay uh when they slander different
individuals that bothers me and then
just when they misrepresent science and
what we do know that really bothers me
but I'm so to talk specifically about
this particular podcast what were some
of the parts in that that you thought
were the funniest like Joe Rogan he did
a couple of really good pushbacks so
I'll say that when it came to actually
talking about biology
Rogan was just so way out of his depth
as I would be yeah you know that's I'm
I'm not calling him a name or something
like that by saying that just most
people would be
um so he kind of just let Meyer just say
whatever and then would be like okay now
I'm gonna ask you about something that I
can actually ask you about uh I actually
I was actually fairly impressed with him
because so at one point Meyer was saying
that you can get like the the beak shape
to evolve but you can't get a beak to
evolve and Joe Rogan did stop from there
and he's like we're talking about huge
time skills here the thing that can
shape a beak can also build one and
Meyer Meyer goes oh well you know time
is always the hero of the plot
and then moves on you know there were
things that of course were Beyond his
ability to push back on but he he did an
okay job I wasn't like I actually that
overall I think you said you couldn't
stand watching that thing but I actually
thought it was pretty interesting I
enjoyed having
Meyer pushed in the way that he was
having him talk so much about like his
his backstory and so you can understand
this and actually there was a last time
I was on your show I said that I I I was
convinced that Meyer was deliberately
misleading his audience actually don't
think that anymore I think Meyer is
probably just
very convinced through things like
cognitive dissonance and so on you know
because my perspective before was like
there's no way that someone with this
much training could be making these
mistakes when talking about these things
but when you just understand cognitive
bias and how that works yeah
um of course that's possible I was I was
not uh
I was not being open enough to the the
possibilities that could have been
happening there so I I believe that
Meyer believes what he's saying you know
I don't I don't think he's a used car
salesman I just think that he's a car
salesman who believes in his product you
know even if they are lemons sometimes
uh I mean yeah like
I
I think that a lot of the time we look
at people who disagree with us and think
that oh because of what we know there's
no way that they could possibly be
genuine in in what they're thinking but
first of all yeah like cognitive bias is
something that's so inescapable that we
are engaging in it right now and don't
even necessarily realize that it's a
harsh reality that everybody has to
accept and it's something that both Joe
and and Meyer were saying in the podcast
you know like you gotta watch out for
group think you gotta watch out for
group thing by the way I go to church
you know
um and I think that like
understanding memetics can also really
help us when you when we're talking
about religion now I think that the way
that Richard Dawkins and Christopher
Hitchens like especially the way the
Dawkins would talk about memetics uh
when it comes to religion was so
reductive I don't think that all
religion are just parasitic memes
um but I I do think that they're they're
like there's validity to memetics and
that's something that like most Scholars
of religion think it's just that it's
not so simple that that's all there is
to religion there's actually adaptive
benefit to religion too uh but there
there are ideas that basically are very
convincing and they are good at
self-replicating and they they tend to
spread and it doesn't necessarily mean
there's truth to them it's just that
they're they're convincing like the idea
that you're going to be burned for all
eternity if you disagree with a certain
conclusion there's a example of a really
convincing memetic you know
um but to bring it back to what I
thought was funny
probably the the funniest moment for me
was
so Joe did a did a very good job of
pushing back on
you know trying to understand where
Meyer's religion fit into this which is
something that Meyer kind of like danced
around at times but then a Joe at one
point was like well I'm just really
happy that you're willing to talk about
this because so many people do dance
around this issue issue I'm glad that
you're willing to just admit that there
is you know subjective religious
experience involved in this and then
Meyer suddenly kind of started talking
about that much more openly which I
think was a brilliant uh move for for
Joe for just making the podcast more in
depth and helping the listener see his
background more but at one point he goes
um
like
Meyer was really dancing around a lot of
Joe's questions and and basically being
like no no I believe this because of
scientific reasons but I also believe
this scientific stuff because of my
personal reasons but my personal reasons
don't cause any bias I just believe
science because of science
contradictory answers and Joe's like so
when you you know came to studying
intelligent design
uh
you did you have like a certain
conclusion that you would already reach
because of religious reasons and then
you wanted to look more into that study
that and back that up more thoroughly
and uh and Meyer's like oh well you know
I believe certain things but no I wasn't
biased because of that and he's like
Joe's like what are you after and Meyer
goes oh yeah no I actually I do have an
ax to grind I just want to know the
truth and Joe goes
right
like I I thought that was pretty funny
in that context but you couldn't you
could make that argument about anybody
that he interviews but it just I felt
like it was very appropriate in that
specific instance one of the things that
he did that I like to see
Meyer was talking about he believes in
the resurrection of Jesus because people
have given their testimony that Jesus
was resurrected and Joe Rogan stopped
and he's like oh yeah but people give
their testimony that Bigfoot exists yeah
pretty good that that was a pretty good
one that uh that will likely be in my uh
I've yet to edit that part of him but
that will likely be in just a little
preview section of our video together on
my channel just it was too it's too good
not to put in there yeah there were
there were a lot of Little Gems in there
so I I appreciated that now you said
that you were also very frustrated when
you were watching it
what what were the things that
frustrated you the most uh so
I mean
you know I I've expressed my interest in
religious psychology uh that's like one
of the main things that I study I I've
looked all over the the US for a
university where I could get a a masters
in cognitive science of religion but it
doesn't really seem like that degree
exists
um I I'd have to get like an
anthropology degree with special
elective courses in religion and
psychology uh but yeah so Meyer
over and over in vote uh ideas in
religious psychology or just you know in
Psychology like social psychology in
general like he's talking about how
group think exists and that's why the
Discovery Institute is not platformed
um that's why they don't like him
especially that uh you know biologists
see uh evolutionary biology as kind of
this um sacred belief because it gives
them it functions to in a similar way to
like religious ideas do mythology does
it gives them some kind of fulfillment I
think that's legitimate that does really
happen
um there were ideas where he was saying
that like
you know people are biased against
people who believe in the Bible uh
because they
have anti-religious ideas and
Joe would bring up ideas about religious
psychology
and be like you know people and Cults
get me manipulated in this in this way
and they feel very fulfilled they feel
like they're having these deep
experiences that confirm their belief
system which was instilled by like this
this cult leader or whatever
um or you know the people who write
religious texts often are trying to
codify power they're trying to structure
power with their writing and they'll
appeal to the lowest common denominator
in certain ways in order to gain power
from basically people will utilize
populist argumentation and populist
ideas in order to codify power and does
the Bible have something like that
and every single time Joe would bring up
something in religious psychology which
is perfectly legitimate to talk about
Meyer would be like no like that is just
showing bias against uh Christians or
what's probably more egregious than
saying that is well learned philosophers
like myself and my colleagues including
people on the other side of this divide
we don't talk about each other's
motivations we just focus on the
argument that's at hand we just get into
you know the actual public evidence for
like the resurrection of Jesus or for
intelligent design we don't talk about
each other's motivations or religious
background or anything like that
and then he would move on as if he's
answered the question
and so there's this massive double
standard that happened over it was
applied over and over and over
throughout the the podcast and Joe never
really wrangled him on it uh I mean I've
made videos about religious psychology
and multiple videos where I've had other
people from The Discovery Institute Dr
Jonathan mclachy say
you know this is just insulting to say
this to to say that religious Believers
you know might believe because of this
sociological reason rather than debating
us on the reasons that we give
and I'm like well
yeah it is insulting if I'm just using
that as a rote alternative to thinking
if I'm just saying that the only reason
you could possibly believe is because
you know you have some cognitive bias
and you're stupid or whatever
but bringing up actual rigorous theories
which have been tested and and have you
know large stores of empirical data
behind them
is a necessary component to this
conversation and it cuts both ways there
are there's you know research about why
atheists think the things that they do
and if you want to bring that up as a
Christian I'm happy to discuss that like
I encourage us discuss I talk about it
my own I I say things that atheists
don't like on my channel and it usually
comes from a place of just
data from uh that's backing up some kind
of psychological model that's not
flattering to atheists or to anyone and
I
if
if there's any type of science that I
see religious apologists of All Sorts
denying it is the psychology of religion
more so than biology more so than
anthropology even and I think it's
because psychology is a much newer field
they don't have any historical precedent
of uh particularly educated apologists
grappling with psychological ideas you
know Freud didn't exist that long ago
and there's sure as hell are no people
that are grappling with the ideas of
like Wilhelm want like in the in the
1940s and 50s inventing like
experimental psychology no one is
actually substantively substantially
trying to counter Carl Rogers in a way
that uses some kind of uh scientific
model or scientific argumentation uh to
to you know argue secular psychology
they just say if this is insulting let's
move on or no that's not relevant here
or they do something which Meyer I don't
think would do and just say oh that's
just demons you know they invoke some
kind of Supernatural monster to explain
it or or combat it uh so yeah that's my
rant on I think that the way that Meyer
and The Discovery Institute handles
religious psychology is absolutely
abysmal and kind of embarrassing I would
I would have no problem with him saying
I'm not a sociologist or psychologist
which he did
um and then being like I don't I can't
really speak on that if he didn't then
go on to speak on matters of religious
psychology and sociology in order to
back at his very own arguments
um like the resurrection of Jesus
argument I'll be discussing in my my uh
video on my channel it's like yeah he's
he's talking about motivation in the way
that psychology works
without any kind of source whatsoever
and then saying that like this is one of
the fundamental reasons he has his
entire world view
it's like whoa come on man that it's a
double standard
yeah uh
there was a
there was a couple of interesting things
that he that I noticed one was that he
was talking about a scientist who quote
Minds people and who misrepresents their
research in the world of physics because
it was a guy who was against the Big
Bang right yeah
it was really easy for him to see
these tactics of quote mining these
types of misrepresentations of science
but then he would go do those exact same
things with Biology that was pretty
interesting for me to watch that he's
capable of seeing this in one area and
not and the other
um or unless he's doing it intentionally
yeah
that was really interesting to see he
did a pretty good job of describing how
it is that we came to our understanding
of the big bang you know he took things
too far but by saying that like
we understand
or or that because of what we know from
The Big Bang that that there was a
definite start where you know a lot of
people are like uh we're extrapolating
backwards and we get to a point that's
right that's what we're calling the Big
Bang right he's being much more uh
like definitive about what that means
theological and what that means yeah
anything else I want to talk about that
that really bothered you or just stood
out during that interview I think that
this is kind of like
a part of
my discussion of platforming which I
hope that we can we can explore some
more yeah yeah it's now let's do that
you know
I don't think that
the way that people like Stephen Meyer
um and another person that uh Joe Rogan
actually invoked in this podcast Graham
Hancock I don't think that the way that
they gain notoriety or uh interact with
their audience is primarily through
delivering
you know
scientific understanding or explanations
or data sets or anything like that or
explaining experiments in the same way
that a lot of other more reputable
scientists would
uh the one of their main strengths is
rhetoric you know Graham Hancock is a
very influential and uh you know emotive
speaker I think that just listening to
the guy makes you think that like maybe
Atlantis is out there I kind of hope it
is because this guy is very moving with
the way he talks and Stephen Meyer if if
you're used to listening to Christian
apologists like I am unfortunately uh
you you hear a lot of the specific
phrasing that he is he's taking from
people like William Lane Craig and and
these these turns of phrase that he uses
are meant to appeal to lay people and
convince them make them feel something
and bring them over to this side where
they start thinking things about science
or about you know Academia or
intellectual matters in general because
this bit of rhetoric was so compelling
um but it doesn't change the fact that
it it is rhetoric uh I've unpacked that
in my long form video when we're talking
about some religious psychology stuff he
use uses specific turns of phrase in
order to sneak in a bunch of premises
and like like you're saying I'm I didn't
in my video and I'm not trying to accuse
him of being purposely deceptive I think
that he thinks these bits of rhetoric
are legitimate arguments they're valid I
mean this is what like William Lane
Craig does all the time uh you know you
you can't make an argument from Evil
that God sends people to hell because
the theology actually is that you send
yourself to Hell how's that any
different I don't know but it is
convincing to people uh so I I think
that you know Joe has this idea and a
lot of people have this idea that we
should talk to each other that we need
to break down these barriers and the
only way we can do it is through
conversation
but I think that a lot of people
assume that or can overestimate
Joe's ability and their own ability to
speak to someone who is highly trained
in rhetoric and see through it there
were many times when Joe did not see
through it and snuck as he's stupid it's
not because he's not a good interviewer
is because Stephen Meyer is brilliant at
using this kind of rhetoric because he
has like a multi-decade career of using
Christian apologetics and this is what
it what it primarily is and so I'm not
really confident in Joe Rogan or most
people not even my ability to have a
conversation with someone like Stephen
Meyer and be able to effectively unpack
all of these things in a way which is
going to make a useful conversation to
the consumer
uh so I I think that while I agree with
this General principle we should talk to
each other I think that the way that
this has had this conversation has had
in a public forum needs to be very uh
it's hard to say controlled but like
intricately planned for and intentional
so that the conversation facilitates
learning and con constructive Dialogue
on the part of the consumer the viewer
not just like the self-satisfaction of
the person who interviewed him I yeah
well I told you I've had Rob Stadler on
I mean he's not a uh like a polished um
he's not a Polish bullshitter he's like
he's uh he's he's a scientist who is a
Christian and he's convinced that
there's problems with original life
research and he didn't like some stuff
that I said in my video I had him on I
really enjoyed those conversations I
think I think we had a fine time uh
James tour you know who James tour is
yeah I'm less familiar with him than
with Stephen Meyer but yeah I'm aware of
him he and I were in conversations about
doing something together because the
stuff that he was saying was just flat
out wrong then Dave Farina just did one
with a minute which was it just went
nowhere I don't know if you saw that but
I didn't see it but I have heard about
it yeah yeah it was just I've heard a
lot about it
James tour is very intense and Dave got
pretty intense and like the two of them
just couldn't really uh maintain a
conversation that was productive I
really like Dave's stuff he has a series
on chemistry that he has on his channel
it's super good it's just an
introduction to chemistry really good
stuff most of his stuff is just these uh
you know basic science lessons or basic
even like politics lessons and history
lessons but he also does these more
polemic things where he'll he'll go off
on people and and criticize him and it's
a little bit it's it's a little intense
for my style this is what I've told him
like he knows that uh you know I don't
share his stuff through standing clearly
very often because it's just so uh
Firebrand
but I do share his stuff on you know
basic chemistry
but yeah his I feel like they ended up
clashing in a way that was not that
productive it just got too
uh personal during that debate yeah I
think that when Educators you know
people who have the ability to have a
substantial debate debate end up uh
kind of doing name calling it it really
undermines their credibility to a large
portion of the audience and it and it it
makes it to where they can be I think
less productive uh yeah and so and you
know it's I'm not trying to necessarily
direct that toward Dave specifically I
think that's just true in general
um if you know getting into polemics
getting into just insulting the other
side is something that we inevitably do
uh I think you you don't have to
you don't like someone like me or
someone like you doesn't have to go you
know I think there's room for all types
in order for all types to exist when it
comes to like getting into Political
diatribes that have a bunch of cursing
involved uh people will do that but then
people like like you and I I think have
to deliberately encourage Educators to
stay on uh like stay on topic and
produce things that are more manicured
and are also more humanizing of one side
for the benefit of the other side
receiving it
um yeah yeah well I I guess I don't
fully agree with you there because I
think that there's um
like
so for with Dave's thing I'm like is
there a pocket of the of the audience
where that was great for them I I'm sure
that there was right because people like
that kind of debate and it's fiery I
mean it definitely got a lot of eyes on
the issue that yeah part of the just the
drama of it got attention to that this
this debate and there's value in that
right but it's just not the it's not the
tactic that I would use I don't really
feel like it's all that my business to
try and get other communicators to
communicate the way that I do or in the
tone that I do I think it's I think it's
fine to have people that are a little
bit you know yeah Firebrand yeah but
it's not my style and I don't even like
watching it I don't even know if I
finished listening to that debate I
might have it was in chunks that I had
to listen to that it was just too much
right it's not something I would really
enjoy listening to either because uh
yeah I've I've experienced so much real
when just kind of expressing that I
don't agree with the status quo here in
the by welt that uh I don't I don't need
to listen to any more of that I know
what it's like uh but I you know I do
think that it's like there can be
benefit to it it can bring eyes uh
but there there also can be a danger to
both either going like really fire
Brands
um but also just in being willing to
platform and debate and put someone who
does not have credentials in what
they're talking about who's just good at
rhetoric next to someone who does uh who
is qualified to talk about what they're
talking about so in the yeah yeah I've
heard that argument it has come up a lot
with covid like with vaccines and stuff
um it's with actually with uh The Joe
Rogan podcast because he wants to have
the Kennedy guy that that yeah RFK Jr
yeah RFK Jr go up against this biologist
who works on vaccines and I can tell
looking at this like this biologist that
he wanted to have on there to talk about
it the guy is he's probably not trained
in rhetoric he's probably just doing
research and going about his calm life
you know you know he's yeah well I mean
the problem is that they're they're just
going to focus on well you're you're
making Health recommendations but you're
not healthy it's super easy to discredit
the guy by just poking at his
nervousness or his you know his obesity
it's like that that's all you have to do
to win these arguments you don't have to
have any facts you can just make fun of
the person exactly and a huge chunk of
your audience is going to uh be on your
side so I can see why that guy in
particular wouldn't do it but you would
think that this part of the medical
community that really focuses on
vaccines they should have people and
that are
public speakers yeah they could go do
that yes I I do think that
this guy needs to be addressed like
you're just letting him say whatever he
wants and no one is there to counter
that's not good right so I we we should
have someone who encountered it I would
be totally happy to have Steve Meyer to
do some sort of presentation with
Stephen Meyer specifically about his
claims that genetic information cannot
evolve and his claims about the genetic
code because I think what we could do if
it was me and him because I I understand
the stuff inside and out I could really
sit down with him and try and figure out
what exactly do you mean when you say
this yeah because we have all of this
data and all of this information right
here what's actually going on in your
head when you're saying these things I
think that that could be a productive
conversation and maybe I'm being overly
confident in my in my my skills here
maybe he could just uh you know use his
uh rhetoric to win in a discussion like
that but I actually think
that because this is a topic that I
understand so well if we could have
rules to keep this focused on this these
are the questions we want to dig into I
think it could be productive I agree
with you on that I think that you would
be a you would be a good person to talk
about this uh alongside Meyer I think
that'd be a fruitful discussion if I was
to do it I know that tons of my audience
would be like oh yeah Drew you should
totally debate him that would not be a
good idea I I don't study biology like I
could probably debate him on psychology
but still I wouldn't be the right person
to do that because you know I don't I
don't even have a graduate degree in
that and so it's uh I I totally agree
with you that I think that it's
dangerous to just expect ideas that are
more extreme or conspiratorial to just
die in darkness that they can just be
suffocated out of existence there's a
reason why these ideas latch on and why
they can grow in the dark you know a lot
of the time they speak to us uh they
they speak to our Dark Side they speak
to the fact that we want to feel special
they speak to the fact that a lot of the
time we are ignorant and yet
overestimate how much we understand uh
and so you know these ideas of like the
moon landing didn't happen and the
government really was doing this with it
it makes people feel
enlightened and special and educated
when they when they believe something
like that we should not expect that to
go away if we just don't address it
um right and so yeah I totally agree
with you I think there should be trained
uh like epidemiologists who are out here
representing this stuff delivering first
of all education in a way that's not in
the debate format but are capable of
taking on a debate and and are specially
skilled and trained in delivering this
in that format for people who are
interested in it
that said
there is a I think that that is not
necessarily a popular opinion among
um the people who like really don't like
Joe Rogan uh right they they're like
okay the opposite of his idea is we
should never talk to conspiracy
theorists and so that's why I believe
that because he's my political enemy and
so I believe the opposite of him but I
think that that's a mistake
um I I also think that just thinking we
should just debate everyone not
particularly carefully as long as we are
like a pretty skilled interviewer but
not specialize in any kind of field of
science someone like Joe Rogan
you know when when the uh
do you remember the the Ken Ham Bill Nye
debate happened in like 2016 or yeah
maybe earlier than that uh so
people that went there to see Bill Nye
walked away from it and were like wow
that Ken Ham guy was an idiot and he got
absolutely destroyed and you know like
uh was it like Rachel Maddow is like oh
yeah Bill Nye destroyed him he's like
such a dumbass
and then
this crazy thing happens within like a
year of that debate the ark encounter
like 185 some odd million dollar
structure gets funded because so many
people saw him debating someone who
represented like the scientific
establishment and going against that and
so creationists and non-creationists
alike were like this guy represents
something that I believe in and so he
was kind of up there either for the
slaughter and so I feel bad for him and
he represents me in a way so I'm going
to donate or it's like no I Bill Nye
just didn't understand what you know Ken
Ham was saying and I'm gonna go donate
to this guy because he's at least
willing to put himself out there and and
so you know things do backfire it's just
it's not so simple as every debate with
a conspiracy theorist backfires or you
know we should debate every conspiracy
theorist on the biggest platform
possible with no particular rules it's
it's just very complicated and
political discourse doesn't like to get
into complicated solutions to problems
like this they just like to scream at
the other side and go I'm smarter than
you you're right this is a this is a
complicated problem the the platforming
issues really complicated I I still
don't know I mean I guess in every
individual case I would have
different opinions I think that's
reasonable it seems to be taken
separately yeah and there's gonna be
people that totally disagree with with
me for being okay with certain types of
platforming like right now
as far as vaccines go for example
we are no longer in a position where
getting a vaccine or not for covid is a
life and death situation so I actually
think that right now is a great time to
start debating this and we have a little
bit more history and a little bit more
understanding of what the actual side
effects were to the vaccine What
percentages that people actually had
issues with myocarditis and all these
different things so it seems like well
right now is a great time for to get
someone who
especially if it's someone who's also
trained in rhetoric to actually to at
least call him out when there is
rhetoric going on one of the interesting
things about Joe Rogan that I've noticed
is that he's actually convincible you
can convince him like Hey this is
dangerous for these reasons so if we're
going to have this conversation can we
put in these safeguards I think that he
can be convinced to put in safeguards
like we're going to have referees that
are there just to fact check that are
there in the room there are ways that
you could have this conversation I would
hope so yeah
I I don't know what it would look like
but it's like
there's we can't just not
address these things because the vaccine
hesitancy it's millions of people that
are scared of this vaccine there's
millions of people that didn't take it
because they thought that it was
dangerous and there are legitimate side
effects and for those people that's
that's their life that's their story so
how do we deal with that as a society
yeah it would be nice if that if there
were people that were able to talk about
those outlier cases in a way that puts
them in perspective you know
acknowledges them without just saying
like oh you know those are just people
crying wolf because they're not but
right they're also a statistical anomaly
basically and we need to be able to talk
about this like yeah yeah right I mean
but it just sucks to be the statistical
anomaly yeah for sure
yeah
um and and it sucks a lot and and you
you get you can get a lot of publicity
talking about it because there's people
that I mean there's it's really
interesting Dynamics and and there
really are companies making millions
billions of dollars off of this vaccine
and that motivates them to do things
that are not necessarily and everyone's
best interest and we have to acknowledge
that and we have to talk about it and if
anything any sort of corruption is
discovered it has to be revealed I I
mean these are things that are very
important to talk about
I guess in general I do lean more
towards Rogan's idea of
more conversation is better but there
are real dangers with it where if you're
platforming someone with really
dangerous ideas you're spreading those
dangerous I mean Joe Rogan's podcast for
example he has such a huge audience that
it's something that he has to very
carefully consider and it actually does
seem like he
he fries like it there was a big apology
he gave
um the Spotify drama he gave this big
apology and said that he was going to be
try to be more careful and when he had a
really controversial person on
especially with medical issues he would
then have other people on that can
counter that yeah I don't know if he has
been doing that but you can you can
easily argue too that like that's that's
not actually going to undo damage you
know people can easily listen to One
podcast like I know of people that I
went
they went to college with that I that I
you know used to live in my old
apartment building like they they
listened to like Joe Rogan and they like
they're totally like have sane ideas
about archeology and then they listen to
like the Graham Hancock episode and I'm
like are you seriously telling me that
you believe in like 10 000 year old
mermaid culture now like where did this
come from and it's like oh Joe Rogan
will absolutely have somebody on
uh several weeks later that's like a a
legitimate archaeologist talking about I
don't know like the discovery of like
homo naletti
um and
just basically spitting facts that can
actually be verified
um rather than conspiracy theories but
sometimes at that point the damage is
done and so again you know I'm not
saying that it's like the the solution
is just be like oh Joe Rogan should not
be allowed to have his podcast anymore
which is what some people say uh I think
that's maybe a stretch but I think I
think there's a very strong argument
that he could do more for there to be
safeguards in place in order to not
misinform his audience
um even in even if you know considering
his audience May listen at some points
and not listen at others like there
there are things that can be done to do
to do better I I hope that he'll be open
to
doing better in the future but all of us
myself included a lot of the time get
focused on
um well this is a controversial issue
this will get ratings this will get
views so I'm going to talk about this
now uh yeah and the actor for it
yeah of course there's yeah there are
there are perverse motives for anyone
who has a podcast yeah I have types of
fun that's that's edgier
but yeah it's it's a hard problem
because it's also at the end of the day
it's like it's a it's a little Empire
that he's built he gets to do whatever
what he wants yeah and that's that's
America you know so uh so it can can
found us even more get us in the even
more difficult territory possibly I had
a question for you
uh because I've been on the receiving
end of of certain accusations
surrounding rounding this because of my
stance that I've made public on it uh
yeah
do you think that there is ever a time
to disregard a person's argument
for something I gotta say a public
figure puts out an argument for or
against something
um is there a time to ever disregard
that argument and be like this argument
is not actually the thing we should be
focusing on this is an aside the real
issue is like the person's institutional
affiliation the person's history the
person's motivations is that ever
appropriate to to do
so yeah you basically you're asking
should a person's reputation matter as
to how much attention we give them right
in a way in a way yeah
I mean for that I would say absolutely
I mean I have to do this all the time
when I'm
considering if I'm gonna spend time
reading a paper right or a piece of
research if I know that the the
researcher who wrote it
does a bunch of bad research I'm not
going to waste my time reading it which
is unfortunate because they might so it
doesn't matter where the truth comes
from like
a horrible person can tell you the truth
and what matters is that what's true
right ultimately but you can definitely
tell uh How likely
is it that this person is telling the
truth based on their reputation that's
definitely yeah we make those judgments
all the time and I do think it makes
sense to talk about a person's history
in a person's
reputation
uh
at least somewhat before you address or
as you're addressing an actual claim
that they've made
But ultimately I mean
what ultimately matters is what's what's
correct and what's not and of course a
bad person can be correct about
something and yeah you know a broken
clock is right twice a day right yeah so
yeah I I think maybe the the most um
the most obvious situation that I've had
with this is
the origin of covid
a lot of people think that we know for
for sure that it was a just oh the
wildlife trade that caused this a lot of
people on the left think that that's
like
totally all the scientists agree that
that's what's happened yeah in reality
that has not been demonstrated that the
lab leak hypothesis has not been
actually ruled out it's only been ruled
out rhetorically we can't say one way or
the other but that the two main
hypotheses that still exist are that
this could have been a research related
accident or it could have been a
wildlife trade the spillover event yeah
both of those ideas are actually still
valid but Donald Trump was the the
loudest and earliest
lab leak proponent like you're talking
about this using his megaphone to talk
about this and so people have refused to
consider that and it's been labeled
racist and so on because he was saying
racist things he used like using slurs
and stuff when he was talking about it
so this is extremely unfortunate because
we we really do want to know exactly how
this virus came about because knowing
this will help us prevent viruses in the
future but there's so much political
backlash like if this was a research
related accident man that's that's
way worse for everybody yeah because
it's like people's confidence in science
is going to go out the window you could
say that the the the government of China
is more to blame because they probably
would have known and that means that
there was a cover-up so there's there's
gonna be political ramifications for U.S
uh Chinese relationships it's a very
expensive thing if it's true Raya but we
do want to know what happened and we
can't just throw this away because As
Trump who said it first yeah he was not
the first person who said it but he was
the first person recognized for having
said it yeah that's a that's a good
illustration of a Counterpoint to kind
of my position that I've put out there a
little bit more recently um so like
daily wire uh Rising Star Matt Walsh who
I don't know if you've heard from much
uh yeah I know who that is yeah he's
talked a whole lot about like trans
issues
um and
basically now we've gotten to the point
where having discussions about trans
Health Care in the U.S is not having
discussions about health care it's
having conversations about
um a grand cabal of internationally you
know politically affiliated
I don't want to get this completely
demonetized so P words uh trying to like
mutilate children because they get
personal pleasure out of it and I mean I
have thousands of people in my own
audience who when I say yeah you know
being trans is like it's a normal thing
like it's okay if you're trans like cool
they'll be like whoa you are you are
promoting like intentional castration of
three-year-olds and I'm like
what what are you talking about
um and it's because like the the
rhetoric that Matt Walsh spreads is so
inflammatory like the idea of whether or
not children should go on to like should
have like uh gender affirming uh Medical
Care at certain ages is a valid
conversation I just don't think it's one
that's that's outside of the
relationship of a doctor a parent and a
child uh it's it's not really for Matt
Walsh to have and to tell everyone in
America that they must have too uh and
and so you know the it gets escalated
from
it it's kind of like a Mott and Bailey
so he puts out this idea of what I'm
trying to do is just protect children
you know that's yeah or like I'm trying
to like you know get at like this big
cabal of abusers
um and we have to like really really
take them down and Destroy them they're
horrible and evil and then you go you go
a little bit further and he's like I'm
all I'm trying to do is protect children
that's really my ultimate goal I just
want to protect innocent kids
however when you read his his books like
his his most recent book that came out
in like what 2020 maybe that's not his
most recent book then uh it's called
Church of cowards the the beginning of
the book starts with
the the fundamental ideas of the left
well first of all the the left is
fundamentally opposed to me and to
traditionalism to the right everything I
represent the basis for the left is
selfishness and the basis of selfishness
is metaphysical evil as found in the
literal character of the devil
so what what you what you get is you
have people saying oh I just want to you
know I want to protect children from
being mutilated by by doctors who just
care about money more than they care
about kids
presents no statistics that show that
this isn't like an epidemic he he
actually was outed on Joe Rogan uh he's
having a conversation with Joe Rogan he
said there's Millions tens of millions
of children who are being castrated
and then Joe Rogan's like
really you really think there's that
many and he's like oh yeah I'm totally
sure Joe Rogan looks looks up how many
kids are receiving or is receiving any
kind of gender affirming surgery and it
was like 8 000 in like four years
in in the entire continent you know and
uh but the the ultimate basis of this
idea is that Matt Walsh is an extremely
religious Catholic who quite literally
believes that if you are not a Catholic
Christian you literally worship the
devil and that the devil is deceiving
you he thinks that the only reason
people are gay is because the devil puts
their fingers in the people the gay
people's minds and turns them gay
and so it's like I've I've put up this
this video where I'm talking about his
arguments
are a smoke screen
ultimately where this is coming from
it's not based in statistics it's not
based in well we need to understand
gender through the through a scientific
lens he doesn't care about the science
he cares about the Catholic church not
being defied metaphysically
yeah I no I think it's perfectly
legitimate to understand people's uh
motives
I mean like
like it was very important to understand
Trump's motives he's trying to not get
blamed
uh himself for the the covet response I
mean the the KKK would put out there
that their ultimate goal was just to
protect white women that we just want to
keep white women safe when we all well
know that that's not what they're trying
to do
and yeah so I mean I see I see the
anti-trans Panic from extremists like
Walsh as being really the same thing so
for the same reason I'm not going to
contend with the idea that he's just
trying to protect you know white women
I'm gonna be like no you're racist
that's what's going on I'm gonna be like
no you you hate people who don't agree
with your religion is the problem
yeah I I do think it's good to point out
people's motives uh but of course you
can't that can't be the end of the
argument like
I mean if you're going to take on
someone's argument I think you need to
look at the meat of their argument and
address that properly too but yeah for
sure people's motives have a huge I mean
we care about this all the time we care
about this if if someone murdered
someone else we care why yeah like
because that that can tell us about this
person's
uh likelihood of doing it in the future
right
uh so that's going to determine how long
they're going to be in prison the
yeah understanding Motors is I think is
is really important it's also really
hard to do accurately yeah people call
it mind reading like of course you can't
mind read but if this scientist is being
paid by Tyson meat industry right
um and he's the one telling you that hot
dogs don't are not at all linked to
cancer right
um You shouldn't trust him as much as a
scientist that doesn't have affiliations
who's saying oh I noticed we noticed
this link like you just you just no you
knowing people's motivations is
important
um in Oregon there's a law where if your
doctor has taken any money including
just a free lunch from someone who who
is a lobbyist for the drug companies
they have to document that and there's a
file there's a website you can go look
on and all that stuff is documented you
know like as yeah I looked at how many
lunches my my doctor had for
presentations uh by such and such drug
company and that helped me actually make
good decisions when he was recommending
drugs yeah that I should be taking so
it's like
yeah we we should know motives
transparency is good yeah yeah I think
you're doing a great job revealing that
stuff but if that's where you end the
argument I don't think that's
appropriate I think you actually do have
to write uh
address the meat of the issue yeah I'm
not I'm not uh so I mean it's like I
guess I would disagree with the the
phrasing I do believe like the meat of
the issue ultimately is the motive when
it comes to people who are ideological
extremists
um and so addressing the motivation like
in the case of Walsh or in the case of
like the KKK is is the like that is the
meat however I do agree that that that
doesn't mean that you shouldn't ever
address any of their arguments
um and just dismiss them entirely
because like I've said conspiracy
theories don't die in darkness like they
they thrive in it and so you do have to
address that it's just not always the
primary focus for everyone who is trying
to begin this dialogue I attempted to
make that uh that point in a video
recently and got a lot of backlash for
it so I appreciate the complexity of
this this dialogue rather than uh that
which happens in the comments section
yeah well I mean another thing too I
mean well he's talking about trans
issues and that is that is
the trans issues are so complicated
because you have
these are it's got all the complexities
of any medical conversation yeah any
medicine conversation like I have ADHD
so I take medication for it
should I be though I mean is it uh and
then should we be giving that to kids at
what age like all this stuff like I
think those are major deciding whether
or not to give your kid a drug is
something you should take very seriously
yeah
and you have um and and so that's that's
in the trans conversation so there's
there's legitimate concerns that people
are going to have
and you can get because it's such a
fight right now because it's like I
would say that the the trans debate
right now in America it's like a bar
fight where you can't walk in there and
try and try and uh just casually say
well I I think that you're being a
little bit
let's listen to there's some wiggle room
here people are going to decide what
side they think you're on and that
they're going to start hitting you with
their chairs like that's a
that's that's how the the trans
conversations are going right now in
American politics so it's it's really
tricky uh
but yeah understanding people's motives
understanding what got them into this
fight in the first place that's all
totally legitimate but I don't think you
can end it there yeah you do have to
you do you do have to admit that this is
a complicated problem yeah
I I think I I think that you are
operating off of a secret agenda and
you're just a total because
you're willing to add caveats any of
this and you know this is just something
that the human mind does is we're like
oh they're not completely on my side and
this is a hot button issue right now so
like this person is the scum of the
earth and uh you know as someone who's
engaged and I'm very passionate about
like the I I hate even calling it a
trans debate which is like you know part
of like the the rhetoric of my side we
do not call it a debate it's like trans
people exist
um and but yeah I try to be cognizant of
the fact that like I'm gonna get really
heated because like
I mean what is it I think like a quarter
of all of my friends are trans uh yeah
like one of my absolute best friends is
trans like half of the people I've even
had collaborated with me on my channel
are trans it's just a thing that I don't
know I just get along with trans people
I guess and so like these people are
very close to me and and so something
I'm very passionate about and I
that passion can be very helpful in in
motivating me but it can also make it to
where
um I'm you know more willing to just be
like this person is an
and and and think that that's a
substantial argument which like
sometimes that's all you can do but
sometimes it's not so it's really hard
yeah the
this actually brings back an another
yeah it's almost
I think we've almost gone two hours yeah
we have but uh maybe maybe
it's it's worth just just opening the
door here on this one one of the things
that he said on morality he said that
there's there's no no one thinks it's
okay to kick an old lady in The Shins
that's like evidence that God gave us
our morals and there you know C.S Lewis
makes arguments like this but
um where our morality comes from God
because where else would it come from
but I
if you're ever living with other people
and you have to cooperate to survive
when would it ever be appropriate to
kick an old lady in The Shins it just
never appropriate like it it there is
just a
ridiculous irony in someone who spends
their life arguing against evolution
to then say where else would morality
possibly come from I can't even think of
of another source
and it's like dude come on you talk
about it every day like at least have
some kind of argument against moral
development the irreducible complexity
of moral paradigms but no it said it's
just like it couldn't have come from
anywhere else so it must be God morality
is is how should we deal with people in
our group
and as our groups expand like you said
you have a lot of trans friends so
you're very sensitive to things that are
that are hurting them I know a few trans
people but not nearly as many but I'm
also sensitive to the things that are
hurting them because I know some some
people have no contact with trans people
and so they're not sensitive to it but
they know people that do have contact
with them so they can actually become
sensitive to it through conversation and
I think that that's
there seems to be this trajectory of
moral progress
throughout history and I think it's
because we have interlocking Social
Circles yes and we're able to win
arguments about this because oh look
I really care about my dogs and so I
don't want people harassing dogs and
hurting dogs and so you end up having
entire governments where it's illegal to
kill a dog uh even if it's a stray dog
whereas nobody cares if you kill a uh
coyote right yeah
um and and some parts of the U.S so
we have these uh these expanding moral
things just because our morals are based
on this is how we treat people in our
group
and that the in-group has been expanding
throughout time I found it
um
pretty ironic when Meyer would just
repeatedly say in the podcast that uh
you know atheistic materialism is is
reductive or the person will say well
and then they reduced the issue to an
atheistic materialist answer and said
basically what you said which is
enormously complicated
and uh and then Meyer will turn around
and say oh the reason why we have
morality is because it's just baked into
us and we don't exactly know how it was
done it's just that intelligence
designed it
um or in in the instance of you know
science coming from Christianity he'll
be like well the only way that science
could have possibly been developed and
the only way that it was developed for
the very first time in all human history
that the only reason why anyone thought
that the the universe could be
understood it could be predictable and
could be understood through observation
was you know because people trusted God
like specifically the Christian God and
they they thought that was a part of
their theology
when
I mean I I don't know how familiar you
are with like the early Greek
philosophers
first of all naturalism yeah naturalism
naturalism was like a valid
philosophical idea for like a thousand
years before Christianity existed
basically
um but they did believe in Zeus some of
them well some of them yes some of them
did and some of them didn't but like the
point is is that you don't have to have
a Christian framework in order to come
to this idea there were Chinese atheists
and naturalists they I mean there have
been tribes uh I think believe it's like
called the pirahad tribe in South
America which is found to have basically
an empiricist
um epistemology throughout like their
entire culture and even in their
language it's just though just like how
Gods can be the idea that gods exist
anthropomorphic agents exist
um in multiple cultures the idea that
naturalism is a thing can also be come
to from multiple different angles if you
look at like who's considered I think
the the first Greek philosopher uh
thales
one of his primary ideas was that we
could learn through observation because
fundamentally the universe is
predictable
I mean this is like 600 years before
Jesus
so and and 2600 years or 2500 years or
something before the Protestant
Reformation
um my mouth is off there but thousands
of years before approximate reformation
and so I think it's actually quite a
reductive answer to say that
Christianity is necessary for this kind
of thought that we've seen to arise from
a plurality of of different people
groups and cultures I don't think we
need to be alarmist about that idea
dying exactly like science if if science
gets wiped out
it will it will be revived if
Christianity gets wiped out it's right
it's probably not going to be uh I think
that's really ultimately what he's more
afraid of yeah it's it's just funny the
the logic there is it just does not
compute it just doesn't hold water at
all
but
well we've covered a lot of ground yeah
uh any final word oh well I I did want
to talk about real briefly who are the
other YouTubers that are talking about
biology and directly fighting against
the intelligent design stuff and the
creationism stuff yeah um so two people
that I that I like are gut sick Gibbon
yeah she was she was actually first on
my list she's I think she's one of the
best right now that directly addresses
creationism the things that the fact
that she delivers are great um she's
able to cite her claims really well but
also she's she's really funny so that
helps yeah um and then also my friend
Jackson wheat I think he does a really
good job of he was second yes
yeah and I mean I I would say also like
I think rationality rules does a really
good job of putting informational videos
out there the thing is is that he does
what I do which is just calls you when
he when he wants to do that
yeah his stuff isn't so much biology but
it's he's done stuff on creationism that
from the philosophical angle yeah yeah
he's excellent for that another guy that
I love trade the explainer have you ever
watched that oh my God yeah Trey the
explainer is one of my like top three
YouTubers I found out that he followed
me on Twitter really recently and I was
I was freaking out it was great it was
it was a great moment for me Trey is
wonderful his stuff is maybe like six
years ago he went on a big thing with
paleontology he would look at animal
corpses and people thought were
dinosaurs or whatever I need to talk
about what they were really really cool
stuff he has one on the biology of
Avatar yeah like the biology of Game of
Thrones and where he would talk about
you know if these organisms actually did
exist how could they have evolved so
he's really good at pulling in
pop culture stuff and making the science
really funny and interesting because of
that he's he's super good yeah there's
another Channel creation myths just
explorers creationism and points out the
claims that are being made and why
they're wrong and then Nature's
compendium is another Channel that I
like and he just does a bunch of stuff
on different fossil organisms and what
they were what we think we know about
them why we think we know those things
and he goes into a lot of detail and he
he does these reconstructed animations
that are pretty cool so and so I have a
couple more people on my list to check
out then anyone else that you would
recommend even podcasts or other than I
mean we talked about Joe Rogan what are
podcasts that you actually listen to
um I mean
I I just I just read books at this point
like I feel like I
I often feel like there's so much that I
need to learn so that I can communicate
to my audience because I never expected
to get this far that I basically don't
do anything except for consume
educational material
um yeah like I watched Star Trek at
night with my wife but other than that I
just am like reading non-fiction books
uh that's awesome but no I mean I I
really like um it's not really like
debunking intelligent designer
creationist stuff but I like basically
all PBS series there's so many good PBS
produced uh YouTube channels now and I
mean there's like things like the Hank
Green produces like scishow Sideshow
tangents is a good podcast
um I think that PBS eons is one of my
absolute favorite YouTube channels and
yeah one of the channels that really
influenced me to be like
hmm so maybe this creationist stuff that
I I was taught you know the evolutionism
is a big lie and they don't have any leg
to stand on they're all just lying like
maybe that doesn't hold up this actually
seems pretty legit for people interested
in like the nitty-gritty of uh
paleontology Darren Nash he's a
paleontologist he has a he has a podcast
I don't think it's still active or it's
really slowly active but he does a
podcast with paleo artist John Conway
where they just talk about different
fossils I would say they're timeless it
doesn't matter that he didn't record it
last week yeah it's just he's going over
stuff about different fossils and
different arguments people have had in
paleontology and it's also they're two
British guys and they just they talk
about they go on lots of tangents but it
it's really fun to listen to them I'll
do I'll listen to them when I'm like you
know doing dishes and stuff like that
the Tet Zoo podcast and I don't know if
that's even on like Spotify and stuff
but it's tetsu com where you can listen
to that I do like listening to Lex
Friedman's stuff on AI because uh so Lex
Friedman is an AI researcher and he has
this podcast he has a he has a lot of
political stuff and a lot of like
comedians on and stuff like that but I I
don't really listen to that that much
but his stuff on artificial intelligence
is really interesting got plenty of good
educational resources to check out
hopefully you know a couple of people
have made it to the end of this thing so
it ended up being a bit of a beast but
well yeah thanks for coming on that's
fun yeah absolutely uh you know anytime
I really appreciate you helping me out
with my video because it's like I could
try to do the intelligent design stuff
but uh it's much better to have somebody
who knows the stuff inside it out to
produce something on it so I I
appreciate that